such moments in your life what you
aspire to that is what is most important for you
further in sports
they are not relationships in life this is our
question yes I will answer you in general in life the
most important thing is that you will die with something no
matter who you are a fighter  you are a janitor there you are
somewhere or an engineer hans no you
teach elementary school there
any person each person
earns in his own way and each
person has a profession but it all has
one end one pit all have one pit
so for me the most important thing  us what I
will leave with what I will leave the Lord will ask me
whether I won Conor or not of course he
will not ask him he is not interested in me he
will ask others what you said what you
did with everything I will answer this is the
most important thing for me
and everything else is that  you are what you are
discussing, some kind of something says that
I am not Russians, she is a Dagestanian, I live there
in California or somewhere I am
not going to discuss this moment, I live in the mountains of
Dagestan and I have a house there, one house
is being built another  and I’m still building for myself
know who I am when you start
discussing some moments I can
say it and leave here from channel 1 this
is the largest channel in the country there will be
people who don’t like me and there will be
chickens from here chickens from here they catch and then
I’ll just say I
have a Russian aspar, so leave these
provocative questions, you asked the question
what to do, but my goal is to build a
village in my country, for example, a kindergarten
school with general education, because the
biggest problem a person has is a fight from when
he doesn’t have the brain muscle of everyone,
let’s read  a person must be able
to write a person must be able to listen he
must see a teacher in front of him from
childhood because without education it is very
difficult for
children to be busy with something I,
for example, when I remember when I was a child, I
go home from training, my father does not
say you need to rewrite 10  countries and
pages from the book it is necessary to rewrite 10
Leontiy charter I have been training all day the
answer does not force
me to follow what he is doing  and when I see
other boys up to
which but my peers who after
training there can play somewhere
to go there and so on I will not have
time and do not have to rewrite
because I know in 20 my father will come
and I will have a warm check 10  pages
for anyone to write for me as if it is very
important it is very important because these
should be occupied by something the population
I think that it will be soon